salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique
aujourd'hui on va parler d'assassinât au
nom de l'idéologie en france les
meurtres au nom de la politique sont
rares la plupart du temps ils sont le
fait d'éléments incontrôlés qui agissent
en marge des partis comme ça a été par
exemple le cas des skins qui ont
assassiné brahim bouarram lors d'un
défilé du 1er mai du fn en 1995
ou alors c'est également le fait de
groupuscules radicaux comme c'était le
cas dans les années 80 avec action
directe qui a assassiné le patron de
chez renault georges besse en 1986
parfois c'est aussi un mélange des deux
des éléments incontrôlés issus de
groupes radicaux
ça a été le cas par exemple en 1981 avec
la fameuse tuerie d'auriol un règlement
de comptes sanglant entre membres du sac
le service d'action civique des sortes
de boulistes radicaliser tout cela
relève d'actions individuelles ou de
groupuscules qui n'avait aucune chance
d'arriver au pouvoir
mais il existe aussi un parti tout ce
qu'il ya de plus institutionnel de plus
légal qui a même des députés dont la
direction a le sang d'innocents sur les
mains pour en avoir ordonné l'exécution
ce parti c'est le parti communiste
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale et à
la libération
le parti communiste a éliminé
physiquement il a exécuté des opposants
n'ont pas des nazis ou des collabos mais
des ennemis politiques de gauche
d'abord parlons du groupe valmy ce
groupe était une sorte de police secrète
du parti dans la clandestinité
si le groupe valmy a fait les attentats
contre les nazis il a aussi éliminé des
opposants politiques et des gêneurs par
exemple ce groupe responsable de
l'exécution de mathilde ardent qui a été
exécuté pour des motifs obscurs
probablement amoureux puisqu'elle était
l'amante de jacques duclos un dirigeant
du parti à l'époque le groupe valmy se
considérait comme une guêpe et ou à la
française et la nature même de ce groupe
implique l assassinat politique
mais ce ne sont pas les seuls à avoir
tué au nom du pcf en octobre 1943 79
résistants emprisonnés sont libérés par
ftp une structure de résistances liées
au parti communiste et sont conduits
dans le maquis de vol dit parmi ces
détenus 500 trotskiste parmi lesquels à
pietro tressos un ancien fondateur du
parti communiste italien devenu
dissident
les trotskystes communiste critique de
l'urss
et de staline était assimilé à l'ennemi
par les communistes orthodoxes à travers
la fameuse figure de leader aux
trotskistes figure de propagande
purement virtuel puisque en fait ce sont
bien les staliniens qui se sont alliés
aux nazis à travers le pacte
germano-soviétique l'un des cinq
trotskiste qui avait peut-être un peu
plus d'instinct de survie que les autres
partira très vite du maquis de vol ni
mais les quatre autres seront exécutés
par leurs libérateurs
quelques semaines après leur arrivée
aujourd'hui encore on ne sait pas de
quel échelon est venu l'ordre de les
exécuter
mais il est peut être venu de très haut
de moscou notamment peut-être à cause de
la présence de pietro tressos et puis la
libération aussi a fait des morts
pendant la guerre de petits groupes de
trotskistes existait dont le groupe
bartha du nom de son fondateur qui plus
tard d'ailleurs donnera lutte ouvrière
et dont les membres faisait de
l'entrisme au sein des jeunesses
communistes
les jeunesses du pc pour les convaincre
de la justesse de leurs analyses sur
l'urss en septembre 44 lors d'une
réunion des jeunesses communistes
trois militants trotskistes pierre et
jean bouin deux frères et mathieu
bucholz sont arrêtés par des militants
du pcf et conduits au siège du parti
pierre sera relâché son frère jean
réussira à s'échapper et le corps de
mathieu bucholz lui sera retrouvé criblé
de balles dans la seine et ce sont à peu
près les seules traces que l'on à des
exactions du pcf exactions qui ne sont
peut-être que la partie émergée de
l'iceberg et la période troublée et la
nature très secrète du parti à l'époque
explique que l'on ait peu de traces de
ces événements les activités du groupe
valmy par exemple ont été mises à jour
en 2007 après l'ouverture des archives
du parti
la mort de matthew bischholtz elle à ma
connaissance et uniquement évoqué dans
un court paragraphe de ce petit ouvrage
de lutte ouvrière
quant à la sphère du maquis de vol dit
elle a été déterré dans les années 90
par l'historien pierre brault et qui
était aussi militant trotskiste
voilà pour ce qui est des meurtres qui
ont pu être documenté mais il y en a eu
probablement d'autres par exemple quand
j'étais jeune et que je militais au sein
du mouvement libertaire parfois mais
évoqué le cas des vieux espagnol ces
lieux espagnol ce sont en fait des
anarchistes espagnols qui avaient fui
l'espagne après leur défaite contre
franco et qui nous manquait la seconde
guerre mondiale eh bien on continuer
leur lutte anti fasciste au sein des
maquis français et il se disait
par des informations de seconde main qui
n'était pas documenté à l'époque et bien
que certains espagnols avaient été
victimes eux aussi des staliniens dans
ces maquis il se trouvait bien qu'en
préparant cette vidéo j'ai trouvé qu'un
livre avait été réalisée sur la question
est effectivement il ya des traces
indiquant que et bien des anarchistes
espagnols qui combattait avec les
français contre les nazis ont été
éliminé physiquement par des communistes
espagnols stalinien eu aussi en exil en
france n'est donc pas que les
communistes français qui ont assassiné
mais aussi leurs homologues espagnols
toujours est il que ces meurtres n'ont
jamais nui à la réputation du pcf ce qui
laisse rêveur quand on voit
qu'aujourd'hui on peut discréditer tous
partis de droite en le traitant de
fascistes hommes pour bien moins que ça
ces meurtres en tout cas en disent très
long sur la nature du pcf et sur son
projet de société de l'époque
au vu de ce que ce parti a fait dans la
résistance s'il avait pris le pouvoir
au sortir de la guerre il est probable
que la france aurait ressemblé à
l'allemagne de l'est pour des décennies
on aurait troqué un régime totalitaire
pour un autre et tout comme le parti
communiste cette vidéo touche maintenant
à sa fin
s'il vous a intéressé n'hésitez pas à la
partager et à vous abonner à la chaîne
et si jamais vous êtes membre du parti
communiste et bien n'hésitez pas à re ag
dans les commentaires ça fera rire les
autres
et sur ce il ne me reste plus qu'à vous
dire à la prochaine